[Music]
in the morning of the 10th day of Rajab
eben Burak and his comrades returned to
the king of England while the Sultan
went off with his bodyguard and his
closest friends to the hill for the
butts on Scheffer Armour envoy's did not
cease to pass from one side to the other
in the hope of laying the foundation of
a firm peace these negotiations
continued to our men had procured the
money and the tale of the prisoners that
they were to deliver to the French at
the end of the first period in
accordance with the treaty the first
installment was to consist of the Holy
Cross 100,000 dinars and 1,600 prisoners
trustworthy men sent by the franks to
conduct the examination found it all
complete saving only the prisoners who
had been demanded by name all of whom
had not yet been gathered together and
thus the negotiations continued to drag
on till the end of the first term on
this day the 18th of Rajab the enemy
sent demanding what was due the Sultan
replied as follows choose one of two
things either send us back our comrades
and received the payment fixed for this
term in which case we will give hostages
to ensure the full execution of all that
is left or accept what we are going to
send you today and in your turn
give us hostages to keep until those of
our comrades whom you hold prisoners are
restored to this the end voice made
answer not so send us what is due for
this term and in return we will give our
solemn oath then your people shall be
restored you
[Music]
this proposition the Sultan rejected
knowing full well that if he were to
deliver the money the cross and the
prisoners while our men was still kept
captive by the Franks he would have no
security against treachery on the part
of the enemy and this would be a great
disaster to Islam then the King of
England seeing all the delays interposed
by the Sultan to the execution of the
treaty acted perfidiously as regards his
Muslim and prisoners on their yielding
the town he'd engaged to grant them life
adding that if the Sultan carried out
the bargain he would give them freedom
and suffer them to carry off their
children and wives if the Sultan did not
fulfil his engagements there were to be
made slaves now the King broke his
promises to them and made open display
of what he had till now kept hidden in
his heart by carrying out what he had
intended to do after he had received the
money and the Frank prisoners is thus
that people of his nation ultimately
admitted
[Music]
in the afternoon of Tuesday 27 Rajab at
4 o'clock he came out on horseback
towards the Frankish army knights
footmen turned and advanced to the pits
at the foot
to which place he had already planted
his tents the Franks on reaching the
middle of the plain that stretches
between this hill and that of Kasaan
close to which place the Sultan's
advanced guard had drawn back ordered
all the Muslim and prisoners whose
martyrdom God had decreed for this day
to be brought before him they numbered
more than 3000 and were all bound with
ropes the franks then flung themselves
upon them all at once and massacred them
with sword and lance in cold blood
our advanced guard had already told the
Sultan of the enemy's movements and he
scented some reinforcements but only
after the massacre the muzzle man's
seeing what was being done to the
prisoners rushed against the Franks and
in the combat which lasted till
nightfall several was slain and wounded
on each side on the morrow morning how
people gathered at the spot and found
the muzzle man stretched out upon the
ground as martyrs for the faith they
even recognized some of the dead and the
sight was a great affliction to them the
enemy had only spared the prisoners of
note and such as were strong enough to
work the motives of this Massacre are
differently told according to some the
captives were slain by way of reprisal
for the death of those Christians whom
the muzzle Mane's had slain others again
say that the King of England thought it
unwise to leave so many in the town
after his departure God alone knows what
the real reason was
[Music]
you